Salut,
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
de la tuerie de Nantes.
Une affaire criminelle mystérieuse
qui fait encore beaucoup
de bruit aujourd'hui.
Elle est plus connue sous le nom
de l'affaire Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès.
Cette enquête est encore
non élucidée à ce jour,
puisque le principal
suspect reste introuvable.
Où est passé le suspect
Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès?
Est-il en cavale?
S'est-il suicidé?
Pourquoi aurait-il tué sa femme
et ses quatre enfants?
Est-il innocent?
Pour vous raconter cette histoire, je serai
accompagné de Liv,
qui marraine ce deuxième épisode.
Bienvenue dans le cabinet Curiouz.
Une histoire qui fait froid dans le dos.
Début avril 2011, cinq membres d'une
même famille sont retrouvés assassinés.
La mère Agnès et ses quatre enfants,
Arthur, Thomas, Anne et Benoît.
Le principal suspect,
Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès,
n'est autre que le père de famille.
Un homme issu d'une famille
aristocrate, catholique,
connu pour être un papa poule,
un homme d'affaires
et un mari en apparence épanoui.
Etrangement, il reste introuvable
depuis la découverte des corps.
Alors, quand et comment cette
histoire a-t-elle commencé?
Le lundi 11 avril 2011,
une voisine s'interroge en passant devant
la maison de la famille lorsqu'elle
remarque que tous les volets sont fermés
et qu'une curieuse note est
attachée à la boîte aux lettres.
Sur ce bout de papier, on peut lire
"courrier à retourner à leur expéditeur".
Les jours passent et rien ne change.
Les volets sont toujours fermés.
La voisine, inquiète,
décide de contacter la police afin
de leur faire part de ses inquiétudes.
Deux policiers s'introduisent
dans la maison.
Tout est rangé.
Les draps sont retirés,
les armoires sont vides.
Pour la police,
cela ressemble à un départ volontaire
et pour eux, rien d'anormal
n'est à signaler.
Mais quelque chose de très
curieux se passe ensuite.
Neuf proches de la famille Dupont de Ligonnès
reçoivent des lettres
signées de leur part.
Dans ces lettres, il est expliqué que toute
la famille a été prise en charge
par le gouvernement américain et transférée
aux USA afin d'infiltrer
un réseau international de drogue.
Xavier se dit espion pour la DEA, la
brigade des stupéfiants aux USA,
et donc, tous les membres de la famille
seraient contraints de vivre
sous de fausses identités et seraient
injoignables pendant plusieurs années.
D'un autre côté,
l'employeur d'Agnès, et l'établissement scolaire
des deux plus jeunes enfants
de la famille, reçoivent tous les deux
des lettres les informant
d'un départ en Australie.
Dit comme ça, ça paraît
vraiment très gros.
Et c'est justement ce qui va attiser
l'inquiétude des proches
des Dupont de Ligonnès.
La famille va informer le procureur
de Nantes de cette affaire très étrange.
Le 15 avril, la police retourne
chez les Dupont de Ligonnès.
Encore une fois,
après les fouilles,
ils ne trouvent rien d'anormal.
Après cela, des fouilles approfondies
sont réouvertes jusqu'au 21 avril 2011.
Ce jour là, les policiers s'attardent
sur l'extérieur de la maison et ils
commencent à creuser sous la terrasse.
Et là, c'est l'horreur.
Ils découvrent des corps
dans des sacs en plastique.
Ces corps sont ceux des membres
de la famille Dupont de Ligonnès.
D'abord, c'est le corps d'Agnès,
la mère de famille, qui est déterré.
Un peu plus loin se trouvent les corps
d'Arthur, de Benoît et de Anne,
trois des quatre enfants de la famille.
Le corps du quatrième enfant, Thomas,
est retrouvé dans une fosse à proximité.
La date des décès est difficile à évaluer,
mais ils auraient eu lieu
entre le 3 et le 5 avril 2011.
Le plus troublant est certainement la
manière dont les corps ont été déposés.
Chacun des corps a été placé
dans un sac plastique
avec un signe religieux,
comme une bougie ou une croix.
Un peu comme s'il s'agissait
d'une sorte de rite catholique.
Et les corps ont été recouverts
d'une couche de chaux afin d'éviter
les odeurs de décomposition.
C'est à peu près à ce moment là que tout
le monde se demande : "Mais
où est le père de famille?"
Où est Xavier?
Il devient très vite le suspect numéro un
et un mandat d'arrêt
international est émis à son encontre.
Avant d'aller plus loin, revenons
un peu en arrière, avant les meurtres.
L'enquête révèle beaucoup de choses
suspectes à propos de Xavier,
laissant penser qu'il serait
peut-être le coupable.
Chacun des membres de la famille a été
drogué par des somnifères,
et tué dans son sommeil avec
une carabine 22 long rifle.
Ils sont chacun décédés
de deux balles dans la tête.
Fait troublant, Xavier avait une carabine
similaire qu'il avait hérité
lors du décès de son père.
Suite à cette acquisition,
il avait même pris des cours de tir avec
ses enfants et s'était renseigné auprès
du moniteur quant à l'acquisition
potentielle d'un silencieux.
Un dispositif qui permet de réduire
le son d'une arme à feu.
Il achète un silencieux
et des cartouches de carabine le 12 mars,
ce qui pourrait expliquer
pourquoi aucun voisin n'a entendu
de coups de feu le soir du meurtre.
Fait encore plus troublant,
il achète de grands sacs poubelle
et un parquet de dalles adhésives.
Puis, quelques jours plus tard,
il achète une bêche, une houe,
un outil qui sert à remuer la terre, ainsi
que quatre sacs de dix kilos de chaux.
Il sont avouer que les coïncidences
sont troublantes et contre lui.
Et pourtant, la police n'a trouvé aucune
trace de sang dans la maison
et aucune trace d'ADN sur les corps.
Ce qui sème encore davantage de doutes.
Alors, où est passé
Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès?
Les policiers ont tenté de retracer le parcours de Xavier
à la suite des meurtres.
Il aurait quitté Nantes le 4 avril et se
serait dirigé dans le sud de la France
avec des arrêts à Pontet, dans le Vaucluse,
ou à Blagnac, près de Toulouse.
Et le plus étonnant, c'est qu'il
ne se cache pas vraiment.
On peut voir sur ses relevés bancaires
qu'il s'est rendu plusieurs fois
dans des restaurants ou dans des hôtels.
Xavier laisse des traces.
La dernière fois que l'homme a
été aperçu, c'était le 15 avril.
Après avoir passé une nuit dans un hôtel
Formule 1 de Roquebrune-sur-Argens,
dans le Var.
On le voit apparaître
sur une caméra de vidéosurveillance
pendant quelques secondes avant
de disparaître à tout jamais,
les enquêteurs ont d'ailleurs repéré un
détail assez important sur cette vidéo.
La sacoche de Xavier,
une sacoche assez longue qui aurait pu
transporter la carabine qui avait
servi au meurtre.
Pour la police cet exil vers le sud était
certainement une sorte de pèlerinage pour Xavier.
Un moyen pour lui de s'arrêter
dans des endroits qu'il avait appréciés
et de revivre des moments heureux.
La grande question, c'est pourquoi
aurait-il tué toute sa famille?
Si Xavier laissait apparaître une image
épanouie dans sa vie personnelle
et professionnelle, ça n'était
en fait qu'une simple apparence.
Il a réalisé de nombreux investissements
dans son entreprise qui n'ont
malheureusement jamais porté leurs fruits.
Il s'est endetté jusqu'à avoir
les huissiers à ses trousses.
Par ailleurs,
il n'a jamais réussi à réaliser son rêve
qui était de s'installer aux États-Unis.
Les difficultés dans sa vie sont si nombreuses
qu'en 2010, il transmet
un effrayant message à ses amis.
Si ça tourne mal,
je n'ai que deux solutions,
me foutre en l'air avec ma voiture,
ou foutre le feu à la baraque
pendant que tout le monde dort.
Est-ce qu'il aurait tué toute sa famille
simplement pour leur cacher
ses problèmes financiers?
En parallèle, il aurait eu
de nombreux problèmes de couple.
Et si, Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès
avait simplement voulu faire
un reset de sa vie.
Pour tout
recommencer à partir de zéro.
Christine, la sœur de Xavier clame l'innocence
de son frère et pointe du doigt
de nombreuses
incohérences dans l'enquête.
Tous les achats réalisés : la chaux,
le ciment étaient, selon Christine,
des outils pour remettre le jardin en état.
Et le silencieux avait apparemment été
acheté afin que Xavier ne dérange pas
ses voisins quand il tirait sur sa cible
dans le jardin.
Encore, selon Christine,
Xavier souffrait de la maladie de Scheuermann,
une infection osseuse qui lui
causaient de grosses douleurs dorsales.
Selon elle, il aurait été impossible
que son frère puisse porter les corps
inertes de cinq personnes et encore moins
se courber sous la terrasse
pour les enterrer.
Selon Christine, la famille aurait été
assassinée par un tiers,
une personne qui se montrait apparemment
menaçante envers la famille depuis quelques temps.
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
nous n'avons aucun élément de réponse.
Beaucoup pensent que Xavier est encore
vivant, mais sous une autre identité.
En juillet 2015, un journaliste nantais
reçoit une mystérieuse lettre
signée du nom du fugitif.
Cette lettre est accompagnée d'une photo
sur laquelle on peut voir les deux fils
de Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès.
Un message troublant, mais qui n'a jamais
donné de conclusions intéressantes malheureusement.
En 2018,
il aurait été reconnu dans un monastère
de Roquebrune-sur-Argens.
Mais, fausse alerte.
Il ne s'agissait pas
de Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès.
Il s'agissait d'un moine
qui lui ressemblait énormément.
Enfin, en 2019,
un homme s'est fait arrêter,
car il ressemblait étonnamment
à Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès.
Mais c'était, encore
une fois, une fausse alerte.
Espérons qu'un jour, le mystère
pourra être levé sur cette affaire.
Et vous, quelle est votre théorie?
Est-ce qu'il s'est suicidé?
Est-ce que Xavier Dupont
de Ligonnès a changé d'identité?
Est-ce qu'il a déménagé en Amérique latine,
comme le suggère
une partie de sa famille?
Est-ce qu'il est simplement innocent?
Dites-le-moi dans les commentaires.
Merci d'ailleurs à Liv d'avoir
participé à ce deuxième épisode.
Je vous invite à découvrir
sa chaîne passionnante.
Elle est en lien dans la description.
Si vous me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard.
Merci à vous qui likez cette
vidéo, si elle vous a plu évidemment.
Vous pouvez vous abonner
à cette chaîne et activer la cloche.
C'est gratuit, évidemment.
Vous pouvez aussi aller plus loin en vous
abonnant à mon magazine papier
qui s'appelle Curiouz.
On est déjà à 14 ou 15 numéros.
C'est un magazine presque mensuel, dix
numéros par an,
directement dans votre boîte aux lettres.
Plus de 60 pages
pour 29 euros 90 par an.
De quoi assouvir la curiosité de votre
cerveau dans tous les domaines.
Vous pouvez enchaîner
sur une autre vidéo.
Par exemple, celle-ci.
C'est l'histoire
incroyable de l'île de la Rose,
le premier épisode du cabinet Curiouz,
ou celle-ci, un casse-tête à 4 444 euros.
C'est très précis !
Prenez soin de vous.
A très bientôt.
Tchao !